Sie wollen Umweltgerechtigkeit,
sie wollen sie jetzt,
und sie haben Unterstützung:
„Omas gegen Rechts“.
Eine von ihnen ist Angelika Mattke.
Als Jugendliche hat sie
für Feminismus demonstriert,
jetzt geht die 66-Jährige
wieder auf die Straße -
für den Klimaschutz.
Das sind unsere Kinder, unsere Enkel.
Ja, es ist, [man] sollte sich solidarisch zeigen
mit den Ideen der jungen Menschen
und sie ernst nehmen,
mit ihnen demonstrieren.
Denn der Inhalt ist ja wahr,
es ist ja wirklich absolut wichtig,
dass etwas stattfindet im Bereich Klima.
Und was soll ich sagen…
Wir stecken in einer Krise!
Hannah Pirot ist 16 Jahre alt, und sie
engagiert sich bei „Fridays for Future“,
sei es auf der Straße, in sozialen Medien oder
auch bei politischen Podiumsdiskussionen.
Die Unterstützung der Senioren findet sie gut.
Die ältere Generation kann uns beibringen,
wie wir am besten an die PolitikerInnen
rangehen sollen und wie wir am besten
was verändern können.
Weil, die haben ganz viel
Lebenserfahrung und Wissen.
Und ich freue mich immer wieder,
von älteren Menschen lernen zu können.
Und wir können älteren Menschen zeigen,
dass wir noch Hoffnung haben und
dass wir was verändern wollen.
Hannah will,
dass sich die Klimapolitik verändert.
Aber auch im Alltag ist
ihr Nachhaltigkeit wichtig.
Also, man kann natürlich aufhören zu fliegen.
Fliegen ist zum Beispiel
innerhalb Europas total unnötig.
Man kann alles mit Zügen erreichen.
Man kann immer Fahrrad fahren anstatt Auto.
Angelika Mattke hat seit 14 Jahren
nur ein Transportmittel:
ihr Fahrrad.
Sie koordiniert das Projekt
Klima-Kiez-Kooperationen
in einer Arbeitsgruppe von
„Omas gegen Rechts“.
Das heißt, wir sehen es
als unsere Aufgabe an,
Nachbarn und Menschen
zusammenzubringen
unter dem Thema Klima und auch so ’n Stück
Stadtnatur in die Bürgerhände zu geben
und Mitverantwortung zu
übernehmen und dafür zu sorgen,
dass unsere Stadt bunter wird,
grün bleibt und auch gepflegter ist.
Dazu gehören Aktionen wie das Gießen und
Pflegen von Bäumen in der Nachbarschaft,
das Säubern von Parks oder
das Verschönern von Vorgärten.
Ich glaube daran,
dass ich ein kleines Steinchen bin,
ein kleines Dominosteinchen,
das ganz viele andere Steine
in Bewegung setzen kann.
Und ich glaube, dass man auf diese Art und
Weise wirklich etwas bewirkt
und machtvoll auftreten kann,
und das ist für mich ein gutes Gefühl.
Die Omas und die Jugendlichen entwickeln
gemeinsam Ideen für die Zukunft.
Denn eines verbindet sie:
der Traum von einem nachhaltigen
und gesunden Planeten.